now what would happen if you consume
mostly
healthy whole grains
for one month well if you haven't tried
that experiment you might want to try it
i did it pretty much my whole life all
the way until i was i think 28 years old
roughly about five years ago and i would
say it probably wasn't the best
experiment to do in my body but
i was really consuming a lot of what i
thought were healthy whole grains you
know the syrups the breads the pasta
this the crackers things like that so
let's do a whole deep dive on these
healthy whole grains to dissect uh some
of the
component parts now the first thing i
want to talk about is fiber right
because they always say like
you know if you eat whole grains you're
getting like two to three times
the fiber
compared to refined grains
well
yes that might be true
but
grains don't really have a lot of fiber
to begin with i mean even like brown
rice only has like four percent fiber
that is not high so one cup of rice has
about point four grams of fat so it's
really low in fat it has about 45 grams
of carbohydrate which is extremely
high
yet it only has 0.6 grams
fiber that's a very tiny amount and it
has about 4.3 grams of protein that's
pretty low too
now what about multi-grain bread well we
have 1.7 grams of fat so that's pretty
low and we're talking about like one
slice okay it has 18 grams of carbs
which is quite high yet only 3 grams of
fiber and about 5 grams of protein
now if you take
celery for example that's like 50
fiber like spinach like just one cup 50
fiber and only four grams of carbs so
you really want to get your fiber from
vegetables not
grain and the next point i want to talk
about is
i mean no one really consumes just 100
whole grain they consume
products with whole grains which come
with refined grains and they come with
refined sugar and a lot of chemicals and
a lot of other things and i've never met
one person who would just take the whole
grain
and eat that okay they usually have it
when it's turned into flour right i mean
who eats just whole grains right you're
going to put them into cereal you might
cook them or soak them or something but
people don't do that they grind them or
mill them into some flour and then they
make another product so when they mill
it or grind it into flour
they then expose it to air so you're
going to lose nutrition just from that
you're going to get oxidation especially
with vitamin e and any other fat soluble
vitamins so oxygen destroys the fat
soluble vitamins not to mention that
flour that you buy that you're going to
make into certain products have been
sitting on the shelf for quite some time
so the more exposed to air it is the
more time the less nutrition but that's
not the real big thing the big thing to
me is that if you're going to consume
something in a flour based product when
you eat that broken down grain which
basically
exposes more surface area of that grain
to your digestive enzymes you're going
to get a spike in blood sugars simply
because
eighty percent of that grain is starch
and starch is a bunch of little glucose
molecules stuck together so when you
heat it
or you grind it or you process it in
some way the digestive enzymes are going
to turn that so-called healthy complex
carbohydrate into simple carbohydrates
as a bunch of glucose molecules so
basically it's very similar to eating
sugar and yes it depends how much you
eat but in this video we're talking
about if you're going to be consuming
mostly whole grains now the glycemic
index is basically it means how
fast
that
product spikes your blood sugars between
whole grains and refined grains are not
significant they're pretty close so
that's one issue but the other issue is
these grains especially whole grains
have a lot more phytic acid than refined
grains and so what is phytic acid phytic
acid is an anti-nutrient it's something
that inhibits your absorption of zinc
calcium iron
magnesium and this could lead to all
sorts of deficiencies especially in
children i'm going to talk about that in
a bit and then we get to the topic of
gluten certain grains have gluten that's
the protein in certain grains and gluten
is very very damaging to your intestines
and it can irritate the intestine it can
create inflammation it can create leaky
gut it's linked to
hypothyroidism especially hashimoto's
and other autoimmune diseases so if you
have a thyroid problem you shouldn't be
consuming any grains whatsoever but
gluten either creates an allergy or it's
a gluten intolerance so a lot of people
cannot tolerate gluten and it's really
surprising to me that even certain keto
products
have
wheat gluten because it's a protein but
it's highly inflammatory so why would
you want to have that in your product
and then lastly we have the problem of
roundup or
glyphosate which is an herbicide which
is almost always added to wheat even
though wheat typically is not a
genetically modified
seed but they still add it so you can
imagine the effects that that can create
on our bodies
so the big problem by consuming mostly
high grains are number one the glycemic
index how fast it's going to spike your
blood sugars now the types of rains that
we eat nowadays are way different than
what we used to consume
way back in time nowadays we have hybrid
grains that are very very high in carbs
and also high in phytic acid so what's
going to happen when you consume these
grains it's going to affect your blood
sugars it's going to affect your mood
okay
talking about having more anxiety
possibly depression
because of the spike in blood sugars
it's going to affect your cognitive
function there's a huge connection
between what happens in your gut and
what happens in your brain
and so if you're getting inflammation or
bloating whatever in your gut it's going
to affect the cognitive function it's
going to probably put you in a brain fog
and then we get the topic of weight gain
right so you're going to gain more
weight
potentially develop a fatty liver and a
lot of these carbs just basically spike
your cholesterol okay so that's number
one number two the phytic acid in these
whole grains um blocks
various minerals and what's really
interesting and you can look this up
i'll put the links down below over
10
million children worldwide die of
malnutrition each year and a good
percentage of these children
die of diarrhea that comes from a zinc
deficiency now take a wild guess how you
would develop a zinc deficiency well
number one animal sources of protein are
not available which is high in zinc
that's number one but number two
cereal okay cereal based diets a lot of
these children especially under the age
of five
are living on cereal and all that phytic
acid can deplete zinc and can set this
child up for diarrhea and even a risk of
dying as well as stunted growth and a
lot of other problems that are related
to the development of our bodies at an
early age now what they're doing to try
to solve this problem is fermenting some
of these grains and giving it to the
kids now i don't know how
popular this is and when you ferment the
grains for 72 hours the microbes that
develop from this shift in ph okay with
lactic acid
start to make an enzyme called phytase
to break down phytic acid
so this is why when you ferment grains
you'll have less phytic acid and more
nutrient absorption specifically with
zinc magnesium iron and calcium and this
is another reason why we ferment our
grains for our chickens we have like 16
chickens and i soak this grain in water
for 72 hours and they eat it up and that
way there's less phytic acid they get
more nutrition all right and the third
point about whole grains is that what it
does to your digestive system you're
going to get gas you're going to get
bloated
you're going to get
inflammation
because the high levels of omega 6 fatty
acids irritate the colon
you potentially can get sibo small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth you can
even develop allergies or even an
autoimmune disorder called hashimoto's
which i put a link down below of that
association so grains are not favorable
for your digestive system some people
can digest refined grains much better
probably because there's a lot less
phytic acid and other anti-nutrients in
refined grains and it's easier to
process of course the other problem is
you're going to just create additional
problems with refined grains
so they both have their problems so if i
had a choice between refined grains and
whole grains well i wouldn't have either
of them all right and then i already
mentioned glyphosate which is an
herbicide which affects the microbiome
there's been an increased association
between glyphosate and increased risk of
celiac which is a digestive issue not to
mention a lot of other issues which i'll
have to do another video on later and
then lastly we have the fortification of
these grains so even though you're
eating these whole grain
foods they still sometimes fortify them
right they enrich them with a few
synthetic vitamins and then they also
throw in some iron in there which is not
the type of iron that your body can
easily assimilate and that's why certain
grains just sit in your gut for a long
time because that iron and just the type
of vitamins they put are just
not the ones that our bodies are
designed to
absorb
like they put in folic acid instead of
folate they put in synthetic versions of
b vitamins to try to minimize the
vitamins that were lost in the process
of refining now for those of you that
are a little bit skeptical of this video
and and don't have any problem with
consuming whole grains we'll go ahead
and try to consume mostly whole grains
for one month and report back to us on
how
you did health-wise now if you haven't
seen my older video that i did on
how to permanently get rid of cravings
for bread
it's a little bit comical you have to
check it out i put it up right here
check it out